Assassin's Creed as a franchise has a
tendency to be very serious it's a
serious game largely featuring serious
characters in serious situations up
against serious odds
this isn't untrue of Odyssey but the
underbelly of ancient Greece was
boisterous joyful and quite frankly very
silly and it's something I don't want
the series to lose when it moves into
the age of Vikings with fall holla
Odyssey is celebrated for its massive
open world and criticized for well its
massive open world being a bit too
enormous whether you love every side
quest and story mission or find yourself
spending a little bit too much time
outrunning the bounty system there isn't
a lack of things to do in Odyssey but
it's discovering just how much of
Ubisoft ancient Greece and its
inhabitants are hilarious and batshit
crazy that makes the inconsistent pacing
and long stretches of travel of such
adelies despite the nature of the core
narrative being quite literally a Greek
tragedy the ancient history buff in me
was overjoyed to see that ub had decided
to have the greeks
not take themselves too seriously in
Odyssey Cassandra or Alexios always have
equipped ready in any situation there's
rampant casual sex and wildly silly side
quests for every murderous cultist that
needs to be hunted or god forbid
transition to the present day there's a
prophecy you've made cast or Alex
accidentally fulfilled by killing a
guy's mom who you thought was a thief
and then boning his dad a specific
comedy of errors that culminates in this
instant classic of a line you killed his
mother and his partner but the prophecy
said partner would scream to the gods in
agony oh he screamed but not in agony
and that's just the tip of the absurd
iceberg for Odysseys quests which often
provide welcome hilarity riddled detours
alongside your efforts to become the
biggest and baddest thing sailing the
Aegean
one of my favorite multistage story
quests revolves around the spottin
Olympian testiclees which is a name I've
now set on the internet you find the
athlete drunken exiled and convince him
to return to Alice to compete in the
Olympics the quest line requires a bunch
of running around
but when you finally arrived at Ellis
and this is the part where I tell you
I'm gonna spoil something so you can
skip ahead if you don't want to know
what happens testiclees promptly trips
over a bowl of fruit on the dock after
trying to hug you
falls into the water and is immediately
eaten by sharks causing you to have to
compete in the Olympics instead between
boning a new person in every port Greeks
pretending to be minotaurs saying via my
mu and a frequent use of the Malacca
expletive fun light moments and those
that make you genuinely laugh out loud
and never too hard to find in Odyssey it
also makes it super easy to empathize
with the reactions of Kassel Alex who
had generally found rolling their eyes
at the madcap Greeks and saying things
like I'm gonna start stabbing until
someone tells me what's going on not
knowing whether a quest line will end in
the dramatic slaying of a mythical
creature or if it's just somebody's
harebrained scheme gone wrong
keeps the quest lines fun even when you
have to run halfway across the Greek
Isles and back to complete them while it
would be a huge shame to miss out on
these moments of comedy when Valhalla
arrives it does seem like a less natural
fit for the Viking culture of brawler's
and Raiders a far cry from the free
loving romantic Greeks though there's a
good argument to be made for peppering
the Viking setting with moments of
appropriate levity and characters that
are unpredictable and exciting
this would help vary the tone of
Valhalla beyond the serious core
narrative just as it did in Odyssey an
important factor if we're to expect a
world just as sprawling as ubisoft's
ancient Greece Valhalla's narrative
director darby McDevitt who was also the
lead writer on revelations in Black Flag
and Cobra unity told us that Valhalla
will be primarily about the struggle of
Viking people seeking a home and the
emphasis will be on the historical
context that all sounds very serious but
McDevitt did clarify that protagonist
evil is a very unique character he
explained I won't get into it too much
but there definitely a leader they have
a sense of humor I wouldn't call them
wisecracking
but they're not stone-faced I don't know
how to get into it without spoiling too
much we already know we'll have an avian
companion again in Valhalla Leila's
story in the modern day will continue
and stealth assassinations will be even
more of a focus with the return of one
hit
kills and social stealth where you can
slip into crowds these are the things
you pretty much always expect Assassin's
Creed to get right but I hope you be
soft brings a little humor and joy to
the stories being counted in Valhalla as
well
[Music]
you